so speak I guess this is somewhat
related to what we're talking about here
but what did you make of the Cavanaugh
thing this is my tape I mean I've spent
a lot of time over the last week paying
attention to it oh really this happened
a little longer
yeah okay so you just caught up on it
yourself for a while I was like this
guy's gross this is gross I don't were
you away when the main thing was
happening you weren't paying attention
okay to it but over the last week I've
paid a lot of attention to it and here's
my take on it one of one of the things
that got me was well one of the things
that got me is it seems like most of his
most of his life in his young life
that guy was [ __ ] up drinking a lot
did you see it read the yearbook did you
see the yeah yeah yeah and all the stuff
about like on the calendar like he had
his calendar and we're like things were
scheduled like beers were scheduled
right it's very bizarre that's very and
he was so like frat boy douchey like all
the stuff he said was very cliquey yeah
and he also lied you know Oh endlessly
yeah sure that alone is all I need to
know yeah he said he said boo f---ing is
farting ranbu f---ing of course means
[ __ ] yeah yeah everybody knows that
that's nonsense so he's a liar so and
then he perjured himself and saying that
he didn't and you know and by the way
the Democrats didn't even mention
perjury they just they just kind of laid
down they just kind of laid down my
whole thing was I I think it was a gross
spectacle and III honestly I thought
that even the hearings happening I felt
like it was a little bit of a clown show
because it's like here we are the most
powerful organization the most powerful
body this government the United States
government we're having this hearing and
we're talking about drinking that
happened in the 1980s right it just
struck me as so silly and silly but at
the same time the thing that you know I
was screaming about and I might may have
literally been the only person in the
country screaming about this stuff I
actually went through Cavanaugh's
judicial record with a fine-tooth comb
hmm and I disagree with him on basically
every decision he's ever made and that's
not an exaggeration he's for warrantless
NSA spying he rules with corporations
87% of the time he said that all of
Obamacare is unconstitutional
channel he ruled that the EPA cannot
regulate greenhouse gas emissions he
even goes as far as to say Donald Trump
might be able to pardon himself so and
that's I mean that's like that was one
of the reasons why they think the Donald
Trump was getting him in the first yeah
but that's but think that's like it was
also part of the Patriot Act yes yes
that's like the end of modern
civilization type [ __ ] because you can't
have somebody above rule of law that's
like a dictator Emperor that's craziness
so the thing that drove me crazy Joe is
that here you have on all those
important issues did you hear a single
Democratic politician bring that up in
the conversations it wasn't it all about
the accusations it was all about the
announcement I'm not saying you can't
bring up the accusations at all I think
you can bring it up especially because
some of them you know seem to have
decent amount of evidence on their side
and seem very measured and reasonable in
their comments she can bring it up but
it just annoyed me that there wasn't
like a two-pronged strategy and trying
to defeat it why do you think that is
because the Democrats sucked Joe
they suck is it just the suck it's then
they suck in the end they and don't use
any pressure to not bring up those
issues no well maybe I guess maybe a
little bit but Chuck Schumer for example
cut a deal with Donald Trump just
recently and he let him approve like I
forget the exact number you guys can
fact check me on this 6 or 10 different
of trumps judges he cut a deal to
approve them so the Democrats can go
back home and campaign for the upcoming
election but it's like hey douchebag the
reason why you guys are struggling in
elections is because you don't stand for
anything so those people wanted you to
fight on those judges because you're not
supposed to agree with those judges
because that's the goddamn opposition
party yeah yeah I don't understand why
they wouldn't bring up all those issues
that you talked about before here is a
demo 50hz I even because two long
missions of 15 Trump judges
yeah and see this is my problem with
them is that you could give them an
issue like take legalizing marijuana in
exchange Dems facing re-election can go
home to camp yeah how ridiculous and
this is what the Democrats do Joe is
that like we were talking earlier about
marijuana 62% of the country now wants
legal marijuana the only democratic
politician talking about it is Bernie
Sanders and maybe a handful of others
and if they ran on these issues and I
can name a thousand others like raising
the minimum wage ending the wars if they
were on those issues they'd win but they
just don't do it yeah well I agree with
you the Cavanaugh's take on all those
issues are pretty [ __ ] vile yeah but
but and it did all those things disturb
me what disturbed me most about what
they were talking about in terms of his
youth wasn't that he did bad things in
his youth it's that he's lying about
them now yeah yeah if he said look when
I was 17 years old I was stupid like
many 17 year olds and I drank but I
never raped anybody yeah did stupid
things and maybe I acted in sensitively
and maybe I said some things that I
should have said because I was a fool I
am NOT a fool anymore and now I am a
judge and now I think I'd make a great
Supreme Court justice if he could say
that but he didn't he got angry and like
him like I watched the video of him
saying I'd like beer yeah it was do you
like it he's asking a senator do you
like it do you like it I like it like
what does that [ __ ] mean you were
talking about you as a teenager when
it's illegal to drink you stupid [ __ ]
and he also did a little sleight of hand
there and said most of the seniors at
the time could legally drink yeah why'd
you say most of the seniors we're not
talking about most the seniors we're
talking about you
he wasn't legally allowed to drink at
the time but that's your right you're
not it exactly right the problem was the
lies the bomb he could have just said
exactly what you laid out there but he
didn't do it which again speaks to his
credibility and it's kind of funny that
the one woman if he did do that to her
the one woman turns out to be a
professor it is hugely progressive super
liberal University who it's almost
predominantly women like if you looked
at how many women are professors at that
university and how many women's I think
it's something like 79 percent of the
women are 79 percent of
students or women at that University and
in some large number of the professor's
or women as well yeah well well at least
one of the allegations were [ __ ]
against him yes
No you know who was right Michael
avenatti that anti-trump grifter who
just wants to get his [ __ ] name in
the media he represented some woman and
there's thousand holes in her story but
this [ __ ] cuz he wants to get his
name in the spotlight
he adds on to the other accusations and
some of the other actions do have merit
and he blows up the whole thing so now
the Republicans could turn around to go
back look what we got here
[ __ ] example so it's all [ __ ] I
think he did it now Sharpton that guy is
a scumbag and by the way he was just a
politican where I was yeah and he's
listen he came out of nowhere he came
out of nowhere and now he's talking
about running for president who the [ __ ]
are you I saw someone say that they
think he'd be great yeah well they said
whoever said that's a [ __ ] idiot well
Bill Mark and I used to like him but
he's gotten progressively worse and
worse